when and how to reopen the economy
policymakers debate as stay at home
orders expire in parts of the country US
intelligence chiefs confirm
investigating if the coronavirus emerged
from a lab accident in China
Amazon's sales jump but its profit
misses expectations while Apple shows
resilience highlighting the strength of
big tech I'm Shelby Holliday and here's
the latest on the corona virus pandemic
from The Wall Street Journal as tensions
grow over lockdown measures protesters
against stay at home orders some of them
carrying rifles crowded inside
Michigan's State Capitol on Thursday
with the stay at home orders expiring in
parts of the US officials are debating
how and when to ease lockdown
restrictions Michigan's republican-led
legislature declined to support the
extension of a state of emergency which
expired at the end of April
governor Whitmer a Democrat has said the
order will stay in place by her
executive authority meanwhile retailers
in Texas and Alabama are set to reopen
with capacity restrictions on Friday
while Florida plans to start reopening
next week some states including New York
and California want to expand testing
and contact tracing capacities before
starting to reopen statewide in a rare
public statement the Office of the
Director of National Intelligence
confirmed investigating whether a lab
accident in Wuhan could be at the origin
of the pandemic US intelligence agencies
also said that they concur with the
broad scientific consensus that the Cova
19 virus wasn't man-made or genetically
modified there's a lot of theories but
yeah we have people looking at it very
very strongly some US officials have
suggested a lab accident could have led
to the pandemic though no concrete
evidence has emerged to support the
theory and the Chinese government has
repeatedly denied it many scientific
experts say it's more likely that the
pandemic was the result of humans being
infected from animals
as homebound customers flood Amazon with
online orders the company reported its
quarterly revenue rose 26 percent from a
year earlier but profit fell Amazon
faces additional costs including higher
shipping costs pay rises and kovat 19
tests for workers Apple says its revenue
rose 1% even as the pandemic shut down
factories and dented sales in China with
strong sales of services and wearables